a final goodbye for southern Nevada's
first black police officer Herman Moody
is being laid to rest today his funeral
underway at Mountaintop Faith Ministries
detective Moody was hired in 1946 when
our city was still heavily segregated he
served for three decades retiring as a
detective in 1977 after his retirement
he continued his passion for mentoring
young police officers his family spoke
about his impact
and I have to say that all of the things
that Daddy taught us all the strictest
that he put on us that I felt was unfair
was more than fair
he protected us
he passed away February 25th he was 98
years old we'll hear more from the
family coming up in our later newscast